This is 99% invisible. 9 Roman Mars Once upon a time, there was a boy named Friedrich Frobo. His early life reads like one of those dark, old, German fairy tales. His mother died in 1783, right after he was born. And so Friedrich Frobo had a lonely childhood. He spent his days in the woods looking at trees and rocks and flowers, wandering
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。很久很久以前，有个男孩叫弗里德里希·福禄贝尔。他早年的生活读起来就像那些黑暗、古老的德国童话。他的母亲在他出生后不久的1783年就去世了。因此，弗里德里希·福禄贝尔度过了一个孤独的童年。他整天在树林里观察树木、岩石和花朵，漫步在
the dense forests of Therinjia and what was then, Prussia. It's a lush region, sometimes referred to today as the Daskruneherts Deutschlands, the green heart of Germany. That's Kurt Colstead, he produced this story. I actually lived near Therinjia when I was a kid, and the forest there are... ...sauberhoffed! Simply magical. And I can really see how Frobo became enthroned. He looked at rocks, he studied the trees, he worked with a forester for a while, he was an apprentice forester.
图林根和当时普鲁士的茂密森林中。那是一个郁郁葱葱的地区，今天有时被称为“德国的绿色心脏”。那是库尔特·科尔斯特德，他制作了这个故事。我小时候其实就住在图林根附近，那里的森林……简直太棒了！简直充满魔力。我真的能看出福禄贝尔是如何受到启发的。他观察岩石，研究树木，还当过一段时间的林务员学徒。
That's Norman Brosterman. He's an author who studied Friedrich Frobo for years. Brosterman says that Frobo worked for a time as a land surveyor and even served in the military. He was skilled at drafting in geometry, and at one point became convinced he should be an architect. He did everything you need to become an architect. He took all the right classes. But he didn't become an architect.
那是诺曼·布罗斯特曼。他是一位研究弗里德里希·福禄贝尔多年的作家。布罗斯特曼说，福禄贝尔曾做过一段时间的土地测量员，甚至还在军队服役过。他擅长绘图和几何，一度确信自己应该成为一名建筑师。他做了成为建筑师所需的一切准备。他上了所有相关的课程。但他最终没有成为建筑师。
A friend convinced him to become an educator instead. And in changing course, Frobo arguably ended up having more influence in the world of architecture and design than any single architect. And that's because Friedrich Frobl created kindergarten. I believe kindergarten had a tremendous influence on the 20th century. It impacted all parts of society, of course, including art and architecture. If you've ever looked at a piece of abstract art or modernist architecture and thought, my kindergartener could have made that. Well, that may be more true than you realize.
一位朋友说服他转而成为一名教育家。在改变方向的过程中，福禄贝尔可以说在建筑和设计领域产生的影响力超过了任何一位单一的建筑师。这是因为弗里德里希·福禄贝尔创造了幼儿园。我相信幼儿园对20世纪产生了巨大的影响。它影响了社会的方方面面，当然也包括艺术和建筑。如果你曾经看过一件抽象艺术品或现代主义建筑，并心想：“我的幼儿园孩子也能做出这个。”嗯，这可能比你意识到的更真实。
The kindergarten was the product of Ferville's decades of experience in a wide range of fields, but the foundations of it were built on the principles of Johann Pestelotzi. Pestelotzi is considered the father of modern education, which basically means they will learn better if you treat them well rather than hit them with sticks, you know. In addition to the whole not-hitting kids with sticks thing, Pestelotzi emphasized physical activity and active learning over rope memorization and repetition. And in particular, he felt that kids should draw. Pestilocy was an early childhood educator
幼儿园是福禄贝尔在多个领域数十年经验的结晶，但其基础建立在约翰·裴斯泰洛齐的原则之上。裴斯泰洛齐被认为是现代教育之父，其基本理念是：如果你善待孩子，而不是用棍棒打他们，他们会学得更好。除了“不打孩子”这一点外，裴斯泰洛齐还强调体育活动和主动学习，而不是死记硬背和机械重复。特别是，他认为孩子们应该画画。裴斯泰洛齐是一位幼儿教育家，
who had incorporated pedagogical drawings in the curriculum. That's author and Cooper Union professor, Tomara Zinger. And basically he is one of the first who thought that drawing should be part of any school curriculum and should be taught to the very, very young. Fribble worked for a time at a school based on these principles. And he built on what he learned from Pestilotse, incorporating his own ideas along the way about how children should be taught. Pestalotti was especially busy with breaking down the two-dimensional world,
他将教学绘画纳入了课程。那是作家兼库珀联盟教授塔玛拉·辛格。基本上，他是最早认为绘画应该成为任何学校课程的一部分，并应该教给非常年幼的孩子的人之一。福禄贝尔曾在基于这些原则的学校工作过一段时间。他以从裴斯泰洛齐那里学到的东西为基础，在教学过程中融入了自己的想法。裴斯泰洛齐主要致力于解析二维世界，
but what Frobel did is break down the three-dimensional world. Frobel realized he wanted kids to go beyond just drawing lines on pages. He wanted them to learn through the physical manipulation of objects. Frobel wanted children to play with toys. Objects designed and crafted specifically for educational play. Now this doesn't sound unusual today, but it really was back in the early 1800s. Children used to go to work with their parents. They used to sit by their parents side and they would play with the detritus of the parents
但福禄贝尔所做的是解析三维世界。福禄贝尔意识到他希望孩子们不仅仅是在纸上画线。他希望他们通过对物体的物理操作来学习。福禄贝尔希望孩子们玩玩具。这些物体是专门为教育性游戏而设计和制作的。这在今天听起来并不稀奇，但在19世纪初确实非常罕见。孩子们过去常常和父母一起去工作。他们坐在父母身边，玩着父母工作留下的废料。
work. I mean, for example, the candlemaker would make wax figurines with the leftover wax. The wooden blocks were only made from the leftover wood from the carpenter. So it was always from the leftover material. Frobl wanted to build real educational intent into objects of play, but it took him decades to come to this key realization, and a lot of time observing children and nature. He was put in charge of an orphanage for a while, overseeing young children, but he also studied the natural sciences, in particular the emerging discipline of crystallography.
我的意思是，例如，蜡烛制造商会用剩下的蜡制作蜡像。木块只是木匠剩下的木头。所以这些材料总是来自废料。福禄贝尔想把真正的教育意图融入到游戏物体中，但他花了数十年时间才得出这个关键的认识，并花费了大量时间观察儿童和自然。他曾负责管理一家孤儿院，照看年幼的孩子，但他还研究自然科学，特别是当时新兴的晶体学学科。
Well, it turns out that the man who invented kindergarten was a crystal scientist. He worked with the foremost crystallographer of the time in Berlin. Where most people saw nature and big, flowing organic shapes like hills and plants and animals, Frobo zoomed in to study the straight lines and the geometric forms of crystals. To try to understand how the physical world around him is actually made. Frobel came to see crystal structures as the building blocks of reality. And this alchemy of crystals and the teaching of Pestilotse and a childhood alone in the woods all crystallized into a solid vision. In 1837, when he was 55 years old, Frobel founded the very first kindergarten
嗯，事实证明，发明幼儿园的人是一位晶体科学家。他在柏林与当时最顶尖的晶体学家一起工作。当大多数人看到自然界中流动的大型有机形状（如山丘、植物和动物）时，福禄贝尔则放大视野，研究晶体的直线和几何形状。为了试图理解他周围的物理世界实际上是如何构成的。福禄贝尔开始将晶体结构视为现实的基石。这种晶体炼金术、裴斯泰洛齐的教学法以及在树林中孤独的童年，最终结晶成了一个坚实的愿景。1837年，55岁时，福禄贝尔创办了第一所幼儿园，
in Badlachenberg, Germany. His intention was to create an educational system for children who could not yet read or write. So he thought to use geometric forms as a way to teach complex and simple lessons all through play. If you can harness play, you can teach kids a lot of things. The word kindergarten cleverly encompassed two different ideas.
位于德国巴特布兰肯堡。他的初衷是为那些还不会读写的孩子建立一套教育体系。因此，他想到利用几何形状作为一种方式，通过游戏来教授复杂和简单的课程。如果你能利用游戏，你就能教给孩子很多东西。“幼儿园”（Kindergarten）这个词巧妙地包含了两个不同的概念。
Kids would play in and learn from nature, but they would also themselves be nurtured and nourished, like plants in a garden. And the key to it all was a set of deceptively simple-looking toys. These were Frobo's gifts. They're called gifts because they were to draw out the gifts of the children. In German, of course, the phrase Frobo's gifts is rolled together into a single word. Frobo goblin. Frobo's gifts were meant to be given in a particular order.
孩子们在自然中玩耍并从中学习，但他们自己也会像花园里的植物一样得到培育和滋养。而这一切的关键是一套看起来简单得令人迷惑的玩具。这些就是“福禄贝尔恩赐”（Froebel's Gifts）。它们被称为“恩赐”，因为它们旨在激发孩子的天赋。在德语中，“福禄贝尔恩赐”被合并为一个词：Frobelgaben。福禄贝尔的恩赐旨在按特定顺序给予孩子。
The toys growing more complex over time. Teaching different lessons about shape, structure, and perception along the way. The first of Frobles gifts was a soft knitted ball. A wool ball. And it's basically the first gift a child could get at the age of six weeks. Then the child would graduate to another ball, roughly the same size as the first. But this one is not soft, it's hard, a wooden maple wooden ball and it has
玩具随着时间的推移变得越来越复杂。在此过程中教授关于形状、结构和感知的不同课程。福禄贝尔的第一个恩赐是一个柔软的针织球。一个羊毛球。这基本上是孩子在六周大时能得到的第一个礼物。然后孩子会过渡到另一个球，大小与第一个大致相同。但这个不是软的，它是硬的，一个枫木球，它有
a surface, it is smooth, it can roll. And then they're given the cube, and the cube is an opposite. It has sides, it has edges, it is sharp edges, it has points. The cube cannot roll. Kids are asked to enumerate the differences between the two. And then they get a cylinder, which combines elements of both the ball and the cube and it blows their little minds. Each new gift would get more and more interactive and more complex. Some were designed to be home from a string and spun in the air. And as they rotate, some very interesting forms are created that are not visible when the form is stationary.
一个表面，它是光滑的，可以滚动。然后他们会得到一个立方体，立方体是球的对立面。它有面，有边，有尖锐的边缘，有顶点。立方体不能滚动。孩子们被要求列举两者之间的差异。然后他们得到一个圆柱体，它结合了球和立方体的元素，这让孩子们感到非常惊奇。每一个新的恩赐都会变得越来越具有互动性和复杂性。有些被设计成挂在绳子上在空中旋转。当它们旋转时，会产生一些在静止时不可见的非常有趣的形状。
Like a cube, for instance, looks like a cylinder when you spin it around fast enough. He wants the children to start to see that there are some invisible parts, contained within the visible. Next up came objects made up of smaller objects, like a cube that breaks down into a bunch of little cubes. And then the toys would ship from being about perception to being about creation. They would become more versatile, client and constructive,
例如，一个立方体在快速旋转时看起来像一个圆柱体。他希望孩子们开始看到，在可见的部分中包含着一些不可见的部分。接下来是包含更小物体的物体，比如一个可以分解成一堆小立方体的立方体。然后，玩具将从关于感知转向关于创造。它们变得更加多功能、灵活和具有建设性，
locks gave way to paper, string, wire, little sticks and peas that could be connected and stacked into structures. The objects would get more abstract and creative, leading to the final lesson. The last is really just working freely with clay. Clay being the most malleable of all. It's rigid and it's soft.
积木让位于纸张、绳子、铁丝、小棍子和豌豆，它们可以连接并堆叠成结构。这些物体变得更加抽象和具有创造性，引出了最后一课。最后一课实际上只是用粘土自由创作。粘土是所有材料中最具可塑性的。它既坚硬又柔软。
And there's a whole range of things a child could build with it. But even at this final stage, this wasn't the kind of creative, free-for-all we tend to associate with childhood play. Frobble had children sitting at desks, little workstations with grids laid out on them. So it's not free play.
孩子可以用它建造各种各样的东西。但即使在最后这个阶段，这也不是我们通常认为的那种随意的童年游戏。福禄贝尔让孩子们坐在课桌前，在铺有网格的小工作台上操作。所以这不是自由游戏。
The fact that the table has an underlying grid is very much at the root of the directed play you follow instructions and there's an underlying order. And so in this very structured, very Germanic way, the gifts encourage students to think abstractly and to relate ideas, objects, and symbols. A set of blocks could be used to teach counting. Then the child could use those same blocks to build a house and then tell stories of a family living in that house. So they were modeling the world in different ways,
桌子上有底层网格这一事实，很大程度上是引导式游戏的根源：你遵循指令，并且存在一种潜在的秩序。因此，以这种非常结构化、非常德国的方式，这些恩赐鼓励学生进行抽象思考，并将想法、物体和符号联系起来。一套积木可以用来教数数。然后孩子可以用同样的积木盖房子，并讲述住在那所房子里的家庭的故事。所以他们是在以不同的方式模拟世界，
all using the same set of objects. The children realized that they can create new shapes and new forms that they create on top of the gridded table. These kindergarten weren't just schools. They were art schools, without other sex and drugs and clover cigarettes. They were places that taught about shape and form and color, and when kindergarten graduates went out into the world, the world changed. The kind of art that was being made in the 19th century is really different than the kind of art that was made after kids went to kindergarten.
全部使用同一套物体。孩子们意识到他们可以在网格桌上创造出新的形状和形式。这些幼儿园不仅仅是学校。它们是艺术学校，没有性、毒品和丁香烟。它们是教授形状、形式和颜色的地方，当幼儿园毕业生走向世界时，世界改变了。19世纪创作的艺术类型与孩子们上过幼儿园后创作的艺术类型确实不同。
Expressionist, cubist and surrealist artists like Paul Clay and Vasily Kandinsky attended early kindergarten Others, like Pete Montreal, encountered forbellian methods as teachers And when you look at a lot of their work alongside illustrations in kindergarten teacher guides, the resemblance is uncanny And it wasn't just artists. Kindergarten influenced designers too. Walt the Gropius started the Bauhaus in 1919. Gropius decided to hire a kindergarten teacher as the first hire of this famous school of design. So the Bauhaus had its adult design students doing geometric exercises, much like those found in kindergarten.
表现主义、立体主义和超现实主义艺术家，如保罗·克利和瓦西里·康定斯基，都上过早期的幼儿园。其他人，如皮特·蒙德里安，则作为教师接触过福禄贝尔的方法。当你把他们的许多作品与幼儿园教师指南中的插图放在一起看时，相似之处令人惊叹。不仅是艺术家，幼儿园也影响了设计师。沃尔特·格罗皮乌斯于1919年创办了包豪斯。格罗皮乌斯决定聘请一位幼儿园老师作为这所著名设计学校的第一位员工。因此，包豪斯让成年的设计学生进行几何练习，就像幼儿园里的那些练习一样。
In the effects of Frobo's work on design education, Rippled out beyond Germany, and some of his most explicit and direct influences can be found among the world's most famous architects. Frank Lloyd Wright, the American architect, is the great child of the kindergarten. You can find the kindergarten and everything right ever did. Frank Lloyd Wright was born in 1867
福禄贝尔工作对设计教育的影响，波及到了德国之外，他最明确和直接的影响可以在世界上最著名的建筑师中找到。美国建筑师弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特是幼儿园的伟大产物。你可以在赖特所做的一切中找到幼儿园的影子。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特出生于1867年，
around the time kindergarten were gaining traction in the United States. And his mom took classes in kindergarten education. Wright never went to architecture school, but he recalls that when he was young, his mother brought home a set of Frobals gifts. Wright said that the moment he was given Frobals' gifts, he, quote, began to be an architect.
大约在幼儿园在美国开始流行的时候。他的母亲参加了幼儿园教育课程。赖特从未上过建筑学校，但他回忆说，当他年轻时，母亲带回家一套福禄贝尔恩赐。赖特说，在他得到福禄贝尔恩赐的那一刻，他“开始成为一名建筑师”。
He went on to say, for several years, I sat at that little kindergarten table ruled by lines about four inches apart. But the smooth cardboard triangles and maple wood blocks were most important. All are in my fingers to this day." And right wasn't the only one. European modernist Le Corbusier also never went to architecture
他接着说：“好几年，我坐在那张小小的幼儿园桌子旁，桌上有相隔约四英寸的线条。但光滑的纸板三角形和枫木块是最重要的。直到今天，它们依然在我的指尖。”赖特并不是唯一一个。欧洲现代主义者勒·柯布西耶也从未上过建筑
school, but he did attend for Ballyen schools in Switzerland. The gridded geometries and repeated patterns of Le Corbusier's modernist houses and apartment blocks look like they were drawn on those gridded kindergarten desks. Look Kaboosie and Frank Lloyd Wright, considered by some the two most important architects of the 20th century, had exactly the same childhood education. And then there's Buckminster Fuller,
学校，但他确实在瑞士上过福禄贝尔学校。勒·柯布西耶现代主义住宅和公寓楼的网格几何形状和重复图案，看起来就像是在那些有网格的幼儿园课桌上画出来的。勒·柯布西耶和弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特，被一些人认为是20世纪最重要的两位建筑师，他们接受了完全相同的童年教育。还有巴克敏斯特·富勒，
famous for pioneering geodesic domes made up of triangles. Fuller discovered his greatest engineering insight as a kindergartener, connecting for brilliant peas and sticks. If you know Buckman's the fuller, this is the thing he's most famous for. You know, the domes made out of peas and sticks basically, nodes and rods. So he learned that in kindergarten. Obviously not everyone who attended kindergarten became a Frank Lloyd Wright or a low-curbucier or a buckee, but the abstract lessons of kindergarten tilled and fertilized the ground, so
以开创由三角形组成的测地线穹顶而闻名。富勒在幼儿园时，通过连接福禄贝尔的豌豆和棍子，发现了他最伟大的工程洞察力。如果你了解巴克敏斯特·富勒，这就是他最出名的地方。你知道，基本上就是用豌豆和棍子做成的穹顶，节点和杆件。所以他在幼儿园学到了这一点。显然，并不是每个上过幼儿园的人都成了弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特、勒·柯布西耶或巴克敏斯特·富勒，但幼儿园的抽象课程耕耘并肥沃了土地，所以
the seeds of their ideas could find purchase in the world. Abstraction was accepted fairly quickly in Paris and in Europe, perhaps because children had already been doing a lot of the same kinds of things for many decades, that was one of the reasons that they were not so shocked when art turned in that direction. So in terms of 20th century art and design, kindergarten was an absolute triumph, but Friedrich Frobel only got to witness the spread of his vision for about a decade before it was cut short.
他们思想的种子才能在世界上扎根。抽象艺术在巴黎和欧洲被相当快地接受，也许是因为孩子们几十年来一直在做很多类似的事情，这就是为什么当艺术转向那个方向时，他们并没有感到那么震惊。因此，就20世纪的艺术和设计而言，幼儿园是一个绝对的胜利，但弗里德里希·福禄贝尔只目睹了他的愿景传播了大约十年，就被打断了。
In the 1850s, the Prussian government was cracking down on the birth thought. And in 1851, they issued the kindergarten for Burt, a national ban on kindergartens. And Frobel died the very next year. And you know, you wonder if he died of a broken heart in 1852. Of course, who knows? But even though the band slowed the expansion of kindergarten in Germany, it didn't stop the idea from spreading elsewhere, far from it. A lot of free-thinking liberals left Germany, and they brought Frobo's kindergarten with them.
19世纪50年代，普鲁士政府开始打击“自由思想”。1851年，他们发布了“幼儿园禁令”，在全国范围内禁止幼儿园。福禄贝尔在第二年就去世了。你知道，你会想他是否在1852年因心碎而死。当然，谁知道呢？但尽管禁令减缓了幼儿园在德国的扩张，它并没有阻止这个想法在其他地方传播，远非如此。许多自由派人士离开了德国，他们带走了福禄贝尔的幼儿园。
So his disciples, they were so dedicated to the work that they immigrated, many of them to the United States. And basically because of the ban, that's what led to the four-bulls, the theories to be known around the world. And the most dedicated kindergarten evangelists were women. As Tomar Zinger points out in her book, Architecture & Play, Frobbel believed that women should play a leading role in educating children. To be clear, Frobble wasn't exactly a feminist. He had very traditional ideas about gender roles and believed that it was the role of women
所以他的追随者们非常致力于这项工作，以至于他们移民了，许多人去了美国。基本上是因为禁令，这导致了福禄贝尔的理论在世界范围内广为人知。而最敬业的幼儿园传道者是女性。正如塔玛拉·辛格在她的书《建筑与游戏》中指出的那样，福禄贝尔认为女性应该在教育儿童方面发挥主导作用。需要明确的是，福禄贝尔并不完全是一个女权主义者。他对性别角色有非常传统的看法，并认为女性的角色是
to nurture children as mannies and kindergarten teachers. But regardless of Frobble's reasoning, teaching kindergarten was a rare opportunity. It was one of the only jobs you could get as a young woman. There weren't many jobs. And it was women who drew up and translated the lesson books that would be used to teach a generation of young artists and designers. By 1885, there were over 500 kindergarten in America, and they were taught primarily by women. And you might be thinking, hey, I went to kindergarten, why didn't I grow up with this incredibly Germanic, amacutly planned sequence of toys?
作为保姆和幼儿园老师来培育孩子。但无论福禄贝尔的理由是什么，教幼儿园是一个难得的机会。这是年轻女性能找到的为数不多的工作之一。工作并不多。正是女性起草并翻译了教学手册，这些手册后来被用来教育一代年轻的艺术家和设计师。到1885年，美国有超过500所幼儿园，它们主要由女性教授。你可能会想，嘿，我也上过幼儿园，为什么我长大后没有玩过这种极其德国化、精心规划的玩具序列呢？
Well, ironically, the passion of some of kindergarten's biggest proponents is part of the reason why you probably didn't grow up playing with Frobo's gifts. The first kindergarten in the United States started in Watertown, Wisconsin in 1856, but it was German language only. The educator Elizabeth P.Body was inspired by this kindergarten and went on to found the first American English-language kindergarten in Boston in 1860. P.Body wanted to spread the teachings of Frobol to as many children as possible, and
嗯，具有讽刺意味的是，幼儿园一些最大支持者的热情，是你可能没有在玩福禄贝尔恩赐中长大的部分原因。美国的第一所幼儿园于1856年在威斯康星州沃特敦开办，但仅限德语。教育家伊丽莎白·皮博迪受到这所幼儿园的启发，于1860年在波士顿创办了第一所美国英语幼儿园。皮博迪希望将福禄贝尔的教导传播给尽可能多的孩子，并且
so she reached out to Milton Bradley, the famous board game maker. She wanted Bradley to mass produce frivolous gifts so that he could be accessible to everyone. And Milton Bradley having heard her was convinced and since that moment it turned his entire attention to the manufacture of fruable blocks and gifts. But where P-Buddy saw an educational ideal, Bradley saw a business opportunity. Bradley began adding a bunch of new toys into the mix, and then other manufacturers got in on the game too, making all different kinds of stuff and just calling it all kindergarten toys.
所以她联系了著名的棋盘游戏制造商米尔顿·布拉德利。她希望布拉德利能大规模生产福禄贝尔恩赐，以便每个人都能接触到。米尔顿·布拉德利听了她的话后被说服了，从那一刻起，他将全部注意力转向了福禄贝尔积木和恩赐的制造。但皮博迪看到的是教育理想，而布拉德利看到的是商业机会。布拉德利开始在组合中加入一堆新玩具，然后其他制造商也加入了进来，制造各种各样的东西，并把它们统称为幼儿园玩具。
He just made up stuff and he said, this is kindergarten and this is kindergarten and this is kindergarten. It's not necessarily fruibles kindergarten. The simple abstractions of frubo's gifts had gone commercial. And within a few years Elizabeth P. Body went from promoting the manufacture of kindergarten toys to speaking out against it. The interest of manufacturers and of merchants of the gifts and materials is a snare. It has already corrupted the simplicity of Frobo in Europe and America, for his idea was
他只是编造了一些东西，然后说：“这是幼儿园玩具，这是幼儿园玩具，这是幼儿园玩具。”这不一定是福禄贝尔的幼儿园。福禄贝尔恩赐的简单抽象已经商业化了。几年之内，伊丽莎白·皮博迪从推广幼儿园玩具的制造转变为公开反对它。制造商和恩赐及材料商人的利益是一个陷阱。它已经腐蚀了福禄贝尔在欧洲和美国的简单性，因为他的想法是
to use elementary forms exclusively and simple materials. Even the word kindergarten itself became a generic term, a catch-all for early childhood education of all different kinds. These days most kindergarten are a lot different from anything Frobl imagined, and few kids encounter those early gifts in any kind of sequence, if at all. But kids still play with blocks. I mean, I really think that it's because of Frobal or Frobal or however it's correctly pronounced that children in the Western world play with blocks. But I think also blocks are a constant across a variety of educational systems,
专门使用基本形状和简单的材料。甚至“幼儿园”这个词本身也变成了一个通用术语，成为各种幼儿教育的统称。如今，大多数幼儿园与福禄贝尔想象的任何东西都大不相同，很少有孩子能以任何顺序接触到那些早期的恩赐，如果有的话。但孩子们仍然玩积木。我的意思是，我真的认为正是因为福禄贝尔，或者无论怎么正确发音，西方世界的孩子们才会玩积木。但我认为积木也是各种教育体系中的一个常数，
Blocks are a constant across a variety of educational systems, because there's so much in them that they can teach. That's Alexandra Lang, an architecture critic and author of The Design of Childhood. Have the material world shapes independent kids. The block is this incredibly malleable toy that can be used in all of these different ways. Proble wasn't the only one to see educational value in blocks. In the early 1900s, Carolyn Pratt debuted her unit blocks. Unit blocks, which are essentially those classic brick-shaped pale wood blocks that really I can't think of any early childhood class from my Vin-2 that doesn't have those blocks. In some ways, all modern toy blocks were influenced by Frobo. Tinker toys, Lego and connects, they're all about understanding shape and form and making
积木是各种教育体系中的一个常数，因为它们能教的东西太多了。那是亚历山德拉·朗，一位建筑评论家和《童年的设计》一书的作者。物质世界如何塑造独立的儿童。积木是一种极其灵活的玩具，可以用所有这些不同的方式使用。福禄贝尔并不是唯一一个看到积木教育价值的人。20世纪初，卡罗琳·普拉特推出了她的单元积木。单元积木，本质上就是那些经典的砖形浅色木块，我真的想不出我认识的任何幼儿班没有那些积木。在某种程度上，所有现代玩具积木都受到了福禄贝尔的影响。Tinker Toys、乐高和K'Nex，它们都是关于理解形状和形式以及进行
connections. But they also represented a parcher from Frobo's highly organized and linear approach. You know, the Frobo blocks you were supposed to proceed from one to twenty through his exercises, whereas the unit blocks are much more open and they're more like we tend to encounter blocks today. These days, we don't think that blocks need an accompanying gritted desk or a syllabus of objects. Now blocks are creative tools for children that give them a chance to use their imagination as they build houses and cities and interact with each other. That's what I see when my boys play with Legos or build castles and Minecraft. There isn't this sense of strict progression.
连接。但它们也代表了对福禄贝尔高度组织化和线性方法的背离。你知道，福禄贝尔积木你应该通过他的练习从一到二十进行，而单元积木则更加开放，更像我们今天接触积木的方式。如今，我们不认为积木需要配套的网格桌或物体大纲。现在积木是儿童的创造性工具，让他们在建造房屋和城市以及相互交流时有机会发挥想象力。这就是我看到我的孩子们玩乐高或建造城堡和《我的世界》时所看到的。没有那种严格的进步感。
It's more a sense that these blocks are a tool for children to recreate their own world as best they can. And who knows how many architects, builders, designers, and thinkers all started with these literal building blocks, for billion or otherwise, learning creativity through construction. The Frobel influenced the design of educational toys, but his ideas also impacted how children play outdoors. That's coming up after the break.
更多的是一种感觉，即这些积木是孩子们尽其所能重建自己世界的工具。谁知道有多少建筑师、建造者、设计师和思想家都是从这些字面意义上的积木（福禄贝尔或其他）开始，通过建造学习创造力的。福禄贝尔影响了教育玩具的设计，但他的想法也影响了孩子们在户外玩耍的方式。休息后即将到来。
Frobles' gifts impacted early childhood education inside the classroom, but Frobles also influenced the way children played outdoors. That's because his kindergarten had literal gardens, little plots where kids could get their hand-starty and learn to cultivate plants. In her book, The Design of Childhood, author Alexander Lang traces the connection between Frobo's kindergarten plots and the very first playgrounds in Berlin, Germany. The first playgrounds were actually piles of sand, which were called sand gardens, which really popped up in Berlin in the 1850s and 1860s.
福禄贝尔的恩赐影响了教室内的幼儿教育，但福禄贝尔也影响了孩子们在户外玩耍的方式。这是因为他的幼儿园有真正的花园，孩子们可以在那里动手并学习种植植物。在她的书《童年的设计》中，作者亚历山德拉·朗追溯了福禄贝尔的幼儿园地块与德国柏林第一批游乐场之间的联系。第一批游乐场实际上是沙堆，被称为“沙园”，在19世纪50年代和60年代出现在柏林。
There wasn't much to them design-wise. They were basically just huge piles of sand dumped in public parks for kids to play around in. And a group of sort of charitable ladies from Boston saw these sand gardens in Berlin and thought, oh, you know, the children in the settlement houses in Boston, the immigrant children don't have anything to do during the summer when schools out. So they decided to bring these sand gardens to New England. Their thinking in part was that dense urban areas didn't have a lot of places for kids to play, especially kids whose parents
在设计方面，它们并没有什么特别之处。它们基本上只是倾倒在公共公园里的巨大沙堆，供孩子们在周围玩耍。一群来自波士顿的慈善女士在柏林看到了这些沙园，心想：“哦，你知道，波士顿安置所里的孩子们，那些移民的孩子，在学校放假时无事可做。”所以她们决定把这些沙园带到新英格兰。她们的想法在一定程度上是，人口稠密的城市地区没有太多地方供孩子们玩耍，特别是那些父母
couldn't afford a big private yard. So sand gardens would be useful additions to cities. So they picked an empty lot in kind of the densest part of Boston. And they just poured a pile of sand in it and said, okay, it's a sand garden come play. And then the kids spent the summer, you know, digging in the sand, making mountains of the sand, playing in the sand. And it was hugely successful. Soon, sand gardens started popping up all over the country, often in public parks. Sometimes they were staffed with play leaders who would teach organized games and marching
负担不起大私人院子的孩子。所以沙园将是城市的有用补充。于是她们在波士顿最拥挤的地方选了一块空地。她们只是倒了一堆沙子在上面，说：“好了，这是一个沙园，来玩吧。”然后孩子们整个夏天都在那里，你知道，在沙子里挖洞，堆沙山，在沙子里玩耍。它非常成功。很快，沙园开始在全国各地涌现，通常在公共公园里。有时它们配备了游戏领队，他们会教授有组织的比赛、行进
exercises and calisthenics and songs, but also more traditional organized sports. There is also this push to Americanize the immigrant children, and so they teach them how to play baseball, which was thought to be a very collaborative and democratic sport. And so the sand garden actually starts to shrink and become a box rather than a garden, a box rather than a whole lot, and they have paved areas and grassy areas. So sand gardens kicked off the playground movement, organized around ideas of American culture, productive teamwork, and healthy exercise. And then there's a whole proliferation of amazing spinning wheels,
练习、体操和歌曲，但也包括更传统的有组织体育运动。还有一种推动力是让移民儿童美国化，所以他们教他们打棒球，这被认为是一项非常协作和民主的运动。因此，沙园实际上开始缩小并变成一个盒子，而不是一个花园，一个盒子而不是整个地块，它们有铺砌的区域和草地。所以沙园开启了游乐场运动，围绕着美国文化、富有成效的团队合作和健康锻炼的理念组织起来。然后还有各种各样的旋转轮、
climbing structures, giant slides, all of this, like, the metal equipment that you can still sometimes find on older playgrounds. In the 20s and 30s, there are catalogs of this and cities buy it. Nearly every city bought into this idea of playgrounds. Seasaws, slides, and swings all became standard features. Actual sandboxes got smaller and smaller, becoming just another thing a playground could have.
攀爬结构、巨型滑梯，所有这些，就像你在旧游乐场上偶尔还能找到的金属设备。在20年代和30年代，有这些东西的目录，城市购买它们。几乎每个城市都接受了这种游乐场的想法。跷跷板、滑梯和秋千都成了标准配置。真正的沙箱变得越来越小，仅仅成了游乐场可以拥有的另一件东西。
In two weeks, we're gonna bring you the story of the rise of the mass produced playground, and the stubborn, super famous artist who pushed back. But next week's episode, we're going to feature the greatest podcast crossover of Ed in history. Seriously, you don't want to miss it. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Kurt Colestead and Emmett Fitzgerald, edited
两周后，我们将为您带来大规模生产游乐场兴起的故事，以及那位反抗的、超级著名的顽固艺术家。但下周的节目，我们将呈现历史上最伟大的播客跨界节目。说真的，你不想错过它。《99%隐形》本周由库尔特·科尔斯特德和埃米特·菲茨杰拉德制作，由
by Avery Truffleman, mixed in tech production by Sheree Fusef, music by Sean Rial. The rest of the team includes senior producer Katie Mingle, senior editor Delaney Hall, Taren Mazza, Vivian Lee, Sophia Klatsker, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. This episode was supported by the Alfred P. Sloan Foundation, advancing public understanding and engagement with science. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Role in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm
艾弗里·特鲁夫曼编辑，谢丽·福塞夫进行混音和技术制作，肖恩·里亚尔配乐。团队其他成员包括高级制作人凯蒂·明格尔、高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔、塔伦·马扎、薇薇安·李、索菲亚·克拉茨克、乔·罗森伯格和我罗曼·马尔斯。本期节目得到了阿尔弗雷德·P·斯隆基金会的支持，该基金会致力于促进公众对科学的理解和参与。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心制作。《99%隐形》是PRX旗下Radiotopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的、极其独立的集体。在radiotopia.fm上找到它们。
You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Ork. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But we have side-by-side comparisons of Pro Bowl kindergarten lessons and famous pieces of modern architecture that will blow your mind at 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与关于该节目的讨论。您可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但在99pi.org上，我们有福禄贝尔幼儿园课程与著名现代建筑作品的并排对比，这会让你大吃一惊。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。